bonjour
j'avais
[Musique]
elle symbolise le 21e siècle digital et
les traditions ancestrales
la corée du sud et ses 51 millions
d'habitants dont la moitié habite la
capitale séoul le pays le plus connecté
au monde avec internet dans 90% des
foyers c'est une nation plein essor
économique et culturel que viennent
conquérir les châteaux du val de loire
ça n'arrête pas cinq rendez vous cinq
rendez-vous par jour dans une grande
ville comme c hall avec autant de trafic
c'est assez rare c'est assez ambitieux
cette fois ci l'entrevue a lieu au
restaurant nous célébrons le 500e
anniversaire de la mort de léonard de
vinci donc c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle vous avez toutes ces visites de
différents châteaux gaël représente le
clos lucé et marque le château d'amboise
de lieux intimement liée à la vie du
génie italien pour les corps est un
moyen simple un moyen mnémotechnique
pour
comprendre le le siècle dont on parle là
on vous parle tant du 16e siècle est le
moyen le plus simple c'est de penser à
prendre un billet de 1000 one de sully à
wang yong et le personnage contemporain
de léonard en corée et wang et astronome
il est également mathématicien et
philosophe tout comme l'était leona les
célébrations de la renaissance un thème
qui arrive à point nommé pour les
tour-opérateurs corinne
c'est le bon moment pour nous de voyager
parce qu'il ya encore cinq ans notre
priorité c'était de gagner de l'argent
c'est ce qui comptait le plus mais
maintenant la tendance est au changement
on cherche plutôt à se cultiver à
connaître l'histoire et à s'ouvrir sur
l'extérieur
donc c'est vraiment la bonne période
pour découvrir ce que les châteaux de la
loire ont à nous proposer
depuis 20 ans date à laquelle les
coréens ont obtenu des passeports pour
sortir de leur pays la société a
radicalement changé
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié de la
population voyages à l'étranger cinq
cent quarante cinq mille coréens
viennent chaque année en france la
destination la plus visitée en europe
devant l'italie l'espagne et la croatie
si paris reste incontournable apparaît
une envie nouvelle de découvrir les
régions une opportunité que tente de
saisir pierre-alain roiron
le président du comité régional du
tourisme est reçu par l'ambassadeur de
france pour promouvoir là encore le
label loire valley les kora sont férus
de technologie c'est un peu de
technologie et quoi de plus beau que
l'histoire veut des marques vinci pour
montrer à la fois la technologie sous
ses aspects purement techniques et
également pour ses implications en terme
de révolution culturelle
léonard de vinci c'est un ingénieur de
la technologie 10 à 500 ans est donc
aujourd'hui encore et c'est très
important la nouvelle technologie
92% des coréennes et coréens ont un
smartphone et les regards des
informations donc il est important que
l'on puisse être présent ici et puis
c'est un marché qui globalement pour la
france et 10 à 15% de plus de visiteurs
chaque année
nous retrouvons les représentants des
châteaux de la loire en plus du clos
lucé et d'amboise il y à chenonceau
blois chaumont et leurs rivaux pour un
rendez-vous groupé chez un des plus gros
tours opérateurs coréens en europe and
actuelle départ des femmes dont deux
reines de france catherine de médicis
donc si vous avez beaucoup de temps vous
pouvez passer du temps au château est
aussi en ville si vous avez moins de
temps en une heure une heure une heure
et demie on peut visiter le château est
ensuite allé à chaud et la vie de
château ne manque pas d'attrait pour les
coréens on a absolument tout pour les
faire venir parce que là nous étions
dans une agence qui était un peu
spécialisé dans les produits de luxe
pour les petits groupes et eux ça les
intéresse directement de pouvoir voir
l'histoire autrement et dans un cadre
tout à fait particulier dans une
thématique particulière en effet bien
côté privilégié vivre leur las de passer
pour attirer les touristes il est
important de comprendre leur culture si
les jeunes corée entre 18 et 20 ans sont
à 100% équipés en smartphone un record
mondial il n'hésite pas à revêtir le
costume traditionnel pour aller faire
des selphy dans le quartier d anouk ces
maisons de bois traditionnels
corinne foulquier la responsable d'atout
france à séoul a pour mission de
promouvoir les richesses touristiques de
l'hexagone en corée du sud elle décrypte
le comportement des coréens pour la
délégation régionale qui s'inquiètent de
l'impact de la crise des gilet jaune
ils sont très sensibles aux notions
sécuritaire mais vous pourrez le
constater ici à séoul ils manifestent
mais manifestent sans violence ça le
droit à manifester c'est quelque chose
de très important donc ils sont pas
effrayés par les manifestations en
revanche l'aspect sécuritaire c'est très
important parce que la sécurité ici
quand on manifeste ça se passe sans
violence la présidente a été destitué
l'a pris 25 ans de prison et ça s'est
passé sans casser un pot de fleurs sans
une arrestation sans brûler une voiture
depuis plus de dix ans le niveau de vie
en corée crois bien plus vite qu'en
europe et le pays est aujourd'hui la 12e
puissance économique mondiale un marché
touristique d'avenir pour le val de
loire
[Musique]
2019 ce n'est pas une fin en soi c'est
un commencement pour faire mieux
connaître notre région à l'étranger et
je crois que c'est quelque chose
d'important le fait même que nous
exerçons nous soyons passés du nom
région centre à centre val de loire ça
veut dire quelque chose donc c'est un
atout qu'il faut pouvoir mettre en avant
de façon importante nous sommes dans une
région où il ya des nouvelles
technologies où il y adeux larchitecture
de l'art contemporain de la culture il
faut qu'on continue à la mettre en avant
[Musique]
m
ça
c'est une soirée exceptionnelle au
dernier étage du plaza de séoul
visiter en cas de sinistre chaque
visiteur à une tablette east au pad et
dans chaque pièce vous avez une borne
sur le sol vous allez l'as canet et la
tablette va vous emmener dans cette même
pièce mais 500 ans en arrière donc
maintenant nous sommes en 15/100 1 et
nous sommes dans les cuisines du roi
c'est très intéressant de se retrouver
plongé à cette époque c'est plus facile
à comprendre
une soixantaine de journalistes bloggers
et influenceurs coréens sont invités
pour cette présentation des 500 ans de
la renaissance
le voyage en france est un marqueur
social donc la france attire les coréens
la région centre val de loire et juste à
une heure où varie ligne avant je parle
un peu le tour soit chartrand ter soit
ou en tgv mais quand vous êtes juste à
une heure de paris après vous avez la
culture ce qui le top numéro un pour les
coréens après vous avez la nature la
région centre à val de loire et quand
même classé au patrimoine mondial unesco
pour ses paysages après vous avez la
gastronomie le vin le no tourisme enfin
je veux dire il ya tous les atouts qui
sont là maintenant après il faut déjà
faire un audit ce qui est disponible en
région centre une fois que le dit
effrayé qu'est ce qui est possible de
faire ce qu'il est possible de proposer
comme produit et l'offre après il faut
la mettre en marché quoi tout simplement
décor est un féru de culture mais qui ne
font pas forcément le rapport entre le
val de loire et léonard de vinci
j'ai visité la région il ya quatre ans
et j'ai vu tous ces beaux châteaux mais
je ne connaissais pas le lien entre
léonard de vinci et la région et je ne
savais pas qu'il était mort en touraine
je comprend mieux l'importance de tous
ces événements dans le val de loire
les manifestations autour des cinq sens
en sont le thème retenu au niveau
national en 2019 pour vendre la
destination france à l'étranger et la
tournée léonard de vinci dans 11 pays du
monde est un investissement de taille
pour le val de loire un investissement
que les élus justifie par l'impact
économique
aujourd'hui dans le pib français la part
du tourisme c'est un peu plus que la
part de la production automobile cc %
pour la production automobile 7% pour
l'activité touristique donc c'est une
activité qui créent de l'emploi qui crée
de la richesse et qui est aussi une
activité d'aménagement du territoire
quand j'ai une région comme la nôtre
[Applaudissements]
oui il
m
genii ça tu habites united
[Musique]
le marathon des rendez-vous s'achève à
séoul avec un gros morceau lagence kuoni
acteur incontournable du tourisme en
asie ici les échanges se font en anglais
devant un parterre deux très jeunes
salariés
des châteaux ce château est très
important pour l'histoire de france
c'est 3 et 10 rennes ont vécu ici
c'était la résidence favorite des rois
au xvième siècle honda 600 chômeurs les
châteaux blois chaumont sur loire et
leurs rivaux ont un temps limité pour
présenter leurs atouts respectifs
sans entrer en concurrence
c'est pas du tout l'esprit au contraire
on essaie de faire quelque chose de
complémentaire parce que l'objectif
c'est de faire venir ces gens là dans
notre région donc il est hors de
question qu'on joue perso on est
vraiment là pour donner une
complémentarité des sites qui de toute
façon est naturellement qui existe
naturellement donc au contraire on est
là pour essayer de les faire venir en
leur montrant les complémentarités
au terme d'un séjour coréen où la
délégation a enchaîné plusieurs dizaines
de rendez vous l'heure est plutôt à
l'optimisme
[Musique]
c'est un pays qui en 30 ans a
complètement changé et ils sont capables
de faire la même chose pour tous donc
c'est vraiment incroyable les offres
j'ai l'impression que ce sont on leur a
parlé ils sont capables de mettre en
place les changements tout de suite
contrairement aux japonais qui met trois
ans des chinois qui tergiverse ci et qui
vont négocier tous les prix c'est pas du
tout les mêmes cultures
celle fille si les festivités des 500
ans font la part belle à l'architecturé
du 16e siècle le présent n'est pas
oubliée pas
justement une façon quelque part à
partir de 2019 de lancer d'un sucre est
en fait une nouvelle énergie pour aller
vers des renaissances qu'elle soit
culturelle artistique technologique
c'est important ce n'est pas disneyland
on va garder notre spéciaux spécificité
notre histoire notre patrimoine mais on
a des nouveaux outils de médiation
maintenant pour faire découvrir ce
patrimoine et le faire aimer aussi
faire du val de loire une marque
emblématique de l'esprit renaissance
dans le monde entier et de léonard de
vinci un ambassadeur universelle est un
pari politique et économique ambitieux
une occasion à ne pas manquer pour une
région qui veut renforcer
son identité